spider-man into the spider-verse is
literally bursting with Easter eggs the
animated movie links to historic comics
and hidden details about the alternate
universe in which the story takes place
there are so many if you blink you could
miss them here are a few of our favorite
secrets you might have missed from the
film spider-man into the spider verse
follows the origin story of Miles
Morales from the moment he is bitten by
a radioactive spider to the moment he
puts on his own black and red Spidey
suit but Miles isn't the only spider
person in this film far from it actually
this is thanks to the villain kingpin
who rips a hole in the space-time
continuum
this causes the collision of heroes from
alternate dimensions Miles gets to learn
from the older adult version of Peter
Parker as well as Gwen Stacy penny
Parker spider-man noir and Peter porker
this film is loaded with references and
easter eggs making it a universally
satisfying experience for comic book
fans as well as fans of the previous
spider-man movies there are so many
quick nods and cleverly hidden gems in
this film if you blink you could miss
them here are a few you may not have
noticed the look of the film it's not
hard to see that spider-man into the
spider-verse looks a lot like a comic
book in fact it looks more like a comic
than any other live-action or animated
film we've ever seen
complete with thought bubbles Binda dots
and hatching viewers felt like they were
watching a living and breathing comic
book the one effect you might have
missed is the background blur and
occasional red and blue lines outline
the animation this is a tip of the cap
to the commonly seen off register
printing errors that would sometimes
happen with older comic books back then
the colors they could use for comic
books for pretty limited that's why
everyone always wore a lot of red and
blue and back in the day when printing
the comic books
the colors had to be printed one at a
time when they didn't line them up right
they called it being out of register
this creates an effect of red and blue
lines sort of leaking out on either side
of the characters making the picture
slightly blurry you can see this in the
earliest moments of spider-man into the
spider verse it's an added touch that
really makes you feel like you're
City among the pages of an old comic
book even if you were not aware of this
effect it probably seeped into some
nostalgic part of your subconscious the
film's writer and producer said that
they liked the idea of taking past
mistakes and making them part of the
language of the movie
additionally the film uses actual comic
book covers remember the part where the
Chris Pine version of Peter Parker is
sharing his backstory and we see a real
Keith Pollard cover on the screen and
then an Eric Larson design takes us into
the Jake Johnson version of Peter
Parker's backstory and Miles Morales
co-creators Sara P Kelly and Robbie
Rodriguez contributed actual artwork for
the film so a mesh of hand-drawn art
combined with CGI came together to
create the artistic design we saw in the
spider-verse movie
according to Vanity Fair Sony is so
pleased with the film's distinct style
they are taking the unprecedented move
to try to patent the innovative
technologies used in this film that
means we may be seen more films with
this distinct style in the future
Times Square posters when spider-gwen
tumbles into the middle of Times Square
we see a lot of interesting posters that
indicate we might be in an alternate
dimension if you pay attention you'll
see slight alterations to some
recognizable films celebrities and
products and posters throughout the
movie there's a merging of the two
popular cult classic films from dusk
till dawn and Shaun of the Dead with the
poster from dusk till Shawn the Blue Man
Group is now the Redman group Starbucks
takes a step back in its history to
revisit its field Joe nalli days Planet
Hollywood became Planet Inglewood Jersey
Boys is now noise boys there's some sort
of Netflix special with Seth Rogen
called hold your horses basketball stars
Blake Griffin and Steph Curry have
become baseball stars and Gogh stars
respectively
one other interesting thing worth noting
is that the value of the dollar is quite
a bit different in miles it's universe
take a look at the check on the table
one fan on tumblr who goes by let Kass
be happy pointed out that the cops in
New York are PD and why coca-cola is now
colas oda and the date on mildest test
reads easton bruere
this fan says that she loves how much
attention was paid to the details
because it makes it obvious that the
story is taking place in a
different dimensions the Spidey suit
fans were absolutely geeking out over
Aunt May's spider cave in particular the
row of Spidey suits
it gave comic book and movie fans a
chance to witness the history of
spider-man's many different looks over
the years the biggest secret gag comes
when they refer to Miles escape a look
Peter Parker is not on board with later
Miles points out a cape suit in one of
the cases as a way to distract Peter
from Mary Jane longtime spider-man
writer Dan Slott said that it is from a
very specific issue of what if slide was
also especially tickled when he saw the
spider mobile in the spider cave here's
a secret fun fact you may not know about
spider-man into the spider verse during
the intro and recap of all the things
spider-man has been up to he says that
they made a cartoon based on him and
that it includes a theme song that
cartoon made spider-man mainstream by
introducing the superhero to the non
comic reading world the cartoon came out
in 1967 and was known for following the
comic books pretty closely even though
the animation wasn't that great due to
budget constraints the show did make an
important contribution to the spider-man
franchise that contribution would be the
spider-man theme song that has been
reproduced so many times over the years
it's so catchy even kingpin sings his
own version of it in the film what
secrets did you notice in spider-man
into the spider verse did we miss any
major Easter eggs or interesting facts
from the film if so tell us in the
comments thanks for stopping by the
things channel if you dig our videos be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to get the latest news
[Music]